okay so now let's talk about math so
last time where we ended was um we were
talking about uniform convergence so we
said that you know our goal for the next
few lectures will be the so-called
uniform
convergence
which means that you want to somewhat
prove that with high probability
if you take soup or maximum I guess soup
really just means maximum uh for this
course so if you take soup over the
hypothesis class and you look at the
difference between
the empirical risk and the population
risk
um you want to show that this is small
um in most like with high probability
so so this is the the general idea uh
and uh and we said that this is
different from showing that so this is
different
from sodium for every fixed age with
high probability
L height H minus l h is small
so these two are of different nature
because one so the the order of the
quantifier in some sense is different so
one requires that if this event so with
higher probability event that the entire
population risk is close to the uh
empirical risk right so the other one is
saying that you just only look at one
single H and you look at what's the
probability that uh this population risk
is different from empirical risk and you
want to show that this event happens
with high probability so so in some
sense the difference is kind of like a
union bond in some sense which I'm going
to talk more on um next when we get to
prove this kind of like statement so
um
so so this is the so I mean this lecture
we're going to talk about two ways to do
this
um um actually we're going to talk about
two cases about H right so certainly
this statement depends on H you cannot
hope to prove things like this for every
possible Capital H it does depend on the
the family of hypothesis you think about
and the bound actually depends on the
family of hypothesis you're talking
about so the first part is going to be
about finite hypothesis class
where H is assumed to be
Finance
so why not
and the next part is going to be
infinite case
infinite hypothesis cost and for
infinite help us cars there are many
different ways to bond to achieve this
kind of bond and uh today we're going to
talk about a relatively Brute Force way
to do it in some sense you do a
reduction to the file and hypothesis
class you know essentially every no
matter what you do you are doing a
reduction to the final hypothesis Clause
but how do you reduce to the final case
you know does matter so in today we're
going to talk about the Brute Force
reduction which does show some kind of
intuition
um
and
uh okay so that's a that's a brief
overview of what we're gonna do with
this
um in this lecture
so
um
so I guess the um
let me just uh you know start by
yeah let's talk about the finite
hypothesis
and here's the serum we're gonna prove
so there are some conditions so the
condition is as we did last time
recorded last time we assumed the laws
is between 0 and 1.
for every x y and every hypothesis
this is true for binary loss it's zero
one loss you know it's not true for
every possible losses but you know if
you have other losses you have to do a
little bit small kind of like fixed uh
to make this proof still work you know
but this is not very essential it's
mostly for convenience
and what will improve is the following
statement so we say that for every Delta
between zero and a half
this is not very important either so
Delta is a small number and you say that
with probability
come on at least
one minus Delta
we have that for every age L height H
minus LH
in absolute value
is bounded by
inspired by
square root
long
the size of h plus long 2 over Delta
over to it
and recall that the reason why we care
about this uniform convergence was that
it's useful for us to bond the excess
risk right so we have shown that if you
have this kind of uniform convergence
then you can prove that your accessories
is bounded so using what we have
discussed last time as a Corollary
we just we we also get IO the excess
risk of LH H hat is the erm minus LH
star
so this is the ERM solution
ioh hat minus LH star is less than uh
you you pay a factor two uh in that
um in that if you know derivation so you
multiply the factor two if so you get
something like two times
loan
size of h plus loan 2 over Delta
over n
Okay cool so
um
all right so
so this is the theorem we're gonna prove
and maybe just uh before we prove the
theorem you can see that the bond the
right hand side of the bound does depend
on on the uh the size of the hypothesis
class right if you have a bigger
hypothesis class then your bond would be
worse so
um so it's harder to prove for con this
uniform convergence when you have a
larger hypothesis class and if you try
to interpret this Bond at the end right
so here this is bounded excess risk and
we can see that
um you need n to be bigger than the log
of the size of H so that the right hand
side of the bound becomes meaningful
right so you want to access risk to be
something smaller than one at least
right at the minimum so you need to be
at least larger than log of the size of
the hypothesis class
so so that's why you need enough samples
right to to have to to make this Bond
you know meaningful
um and of course as n goes to Infinity
you have you know
um um on you have um better and better
box I'm going to have a little more
discussion after we prove the theorem
okay so so now let's try to improve the
theorem
um so I guess the the
outline of the proof
is that first you do individual
h
you prove this for individuals you prove
the the simple version basically like we
discussed the last time and second uh we
take a unit bound
over all h
okay so so let's do the first step
so
um recall that last time we have um
done this already for fixated right so
here I'm just doing a little bit more
formally so last time we actually uh
showed this right we we did we use this
half inequality to get something like L
height Theta minus L Theta this is you
know something like on order of
one over scorpion that's what we did
somewhat informally last time with half
the inequality and today I'm going to
have a little more kind of like careful
um derivations to get exactly all the
dependencies of the constant and by the
way Theta and H are the same H is just
when you talk about finite hypothesis
class right you don't necessarily have a
parameter you may you you may just list
all the hypotheses that's why it's
called H and when you parameterize it
you have the parameter Theta so but but
for this purpose they are they're not
different at all so so let's uh let's
apply this is the last lecture
so let's apply uh half the inequality
so where
AI is zero bi is one
so the bond is zero and one right so and
so we got that for every age in age
right so suppose this H is fixed and
then you draw your sample you look at
the probability that
L height H minus LH
is less than Epsilon
and here was random the random is the
data set the randomness come from the
data set which you know goes into L hat
and if you use the the Hoffman call you
get this is larger than one minus two
times exponential minus two n Square
Epsilon Square
over sum of beta i b i minus AI Square
and
because bi is one and AI is zero so the
sum of BS minus AI square is n so you
get 1 minus 2 exponential minus two and
Epsilon Square
and uh right this is because bi is one
AI zero
and
so in other words if you look at the
other side of the bound we look at
what's the chance that they are
different
the chance that they are different is
less than two times exponential
to n minus x square actually in many
cases half the inequality was stated in
this this way instead of the way that I
showed before no they are exactly the
same it's just complementary of each
other but you have
a lower Bound for some prob some events
then you have the upper bounds for the
complementary of the events
so I know this is for every age you have
this right so so basically for average
you have a some kind of failure uh event
which is this event and this event
happens with a small probability
and now let's recall that you have the
so-called Union Bond
and the union bonds is saying that if
you look at the union of a bunch of
events
maybe let's say k events then they are
smaller than the probability of the sum
of the problem of each event
and here suppose you say the e
H corresponds to the event
that L hat H is different from LH
by Epsilon
then you know that the probability that
the union of the Eis which is basically
saying that
what's the unit of this value basically
means that there exists h
such that this event happens right so
such the LH minus l h l h minus LH is
larger than Epsilon so this is the
um
the the unit of all of these events
uh and it's less than the sum of
the
each of the events
okay so and now you plug in what you
have prepared maybe let's say this
equation let's call it one
so if you plug in one then you get this
is sum over
the all the edges and you get two times
exponential minus two and Epsilon Square
so each of these event is small and you
you multiply by the total number of
uh the possible events which is the size
of H so basically a 2 times H times
exponential that's to an Epsilon Square
right
so
and and you can see that this is
basically what we wanted to have because
now we have there exist H such that this
um
such that they are different so the
complementary of this will be just that
this is just equals to
1 minus the probability that for average
age
the flip event is true
so
by the way I'm not distinguishing the
ladder or to equal or like a
in most of this course like a
um so technically I probably should
write this is less than Epsilon
right instead of like less than or equal
to Epsilon but you know for for this
part for this course like I'm not
super careful about this because they
don't really matter that much
um and in many cases it's actually the
the probability that you you actually
this is exactly equal to Epsilon is
actually zero so so technically they are
even correct but anyway so
um so this is not super important for
this course
um so so but
right when you um so because of this you
can see that this is what we care about
right for every h l hat H is close to LH
and we are already kind of getting there
almost right so the only thing we need
is to know what this quantity is right
we need to Upper bond this so that we
can lower bounds on this probability
okay so now let's choose Epsilon right
so that uh you can get a
um so basically you want that you want
this probability to happen you want this
thing to
to be bigger than one minus Delta so
that's why you want
this
to be less than Delta
right so
um so basically we just need to choose
episode so that this probability becomes
Delta so choose Epsilon
such that
2 h
times exponential minus 2 and Epsilon
square is equals to the outer
and this involves you solve the equation
you know which is not too hard so if you
solve it you got Epsilon is equals to
um
I guess exactly what I had before so
Epsilon is equals to loan h plus
law and two over Delta over n
uh over 2.
so so basically if you take absolute
with this then you know that the
probability that
for average
L has H minus maybe less maybe let's
start with the existence
o h
it's bigger than Epsilon it's less than
it's
less than one less than Delta
right so and then if you flip the event
you get the desired zero
questions so far
okay so
um
let me have a few remarks to kind of
somewhat interpret what we have done and
compare it with what we did in the first
lecture so if you compare
we'll compare with the asymptotic
results
you're going to see this right so for
asymptotics results
what you got is that LH hat minus LH
star
by the excess risk is bonded by is
something like C Over N plus eight over
n and recall that this C
you know can depend on
dimension
on the problem
the problem and here you can hide
uh any other dependencies
dependencies
on the problem
so and what we have now
is that LH hat the excess risk minus the
uh sorry iOS
the excess risk
is
smaller than
um so here you don't hide anything
you hide some costs in the force you
have this is low long h
over n
over sorry square roots
this
uh and of course you also have something
like oh
square root long
well over Delta over it
so this term is supposed to be
relatively small because you can check
the outer to be this is the logarithmic
right you can take Delta to be something
like maybe n to the 10 right so you
still get log n over square root login
over square root n right so let's say
take
they also to be into the minus 10. so
then this one will be square root log
and overscripted which is negligible
um or almost liquid compared to the
first term
so
um so so basically let's say we ignore
this for the comparison so
ignore this for the comparison then you
can compare this and this
so you can see that
um the the first thing is that we have a
worse dependency
dependency on and right before the
dependency at least for the leading term
at least in terms of leading term the
dependency on and what's one over n and
now it's one over square root And So It
Goes To Zero uh slower
um
um so however there's no
um
um so so this could be improved this can
be improved
uh in certain cases which we probably
wouldn't do at all
um
I guess uh um in one of the homework
question you're gonna be asked to
improve this to some extent
um in some cases you can improve this to
one over n uh depending on you know
various situations but generally I guess
you get relatively worse dependency on
end uh in uh comparatory asymptotics
um and and one of the reasons why this
is the the reason one of the reason why
this is happening is that
um
so partly
because
we didn't assume uh twice
differentiability
um loss function right so here our loss
function is only the only assumption we
have on loss functions between zero and
one so it even works for like zero one
loss the classification zero one loss
but before we did assume that the loss
has to be continuous and differentiable
and I think we also assume is twice
differentiable so that does say a
fundamental role here so when you have
when you don't have first vegetability
um um we and and when you don't have
other assumptions it's very hard to it's
kind of like actually impossible to get
uh well over and related medications
so
um but here you know what I'm talking
here is
um all about the downside of our new
Bond so the pros you know we actually
already kind of like mentioned the the
main Pro is that now we don't have any
dependencies uh about anything right so
before we recall that last time we
motivated to have known asymptotic bonds
we are saying that this thing could hide
a lot of things right this could hide
for example
something like that mentioned to the 50
that's my extreme example Over N square
right so P to the 50 Over N Square will
be counted as little while Over N right
so that doesn't make a lot of sense just
because if your dimension is too high
then this is a this requires them to be
very big to be small right so so this
this was the issue
um that we uh we mentioned last time
about asymptotics and and now we fix
that issue and that's the main benefit
we gain right so we don't have anything
about the uh uh the dependencies and
also we expect to see what's the
um
how does this depend on the the
complexity in some sense of the of the
hypothesis class you can think of this
as a complexity
the long h
can be think of as a complexity
of the hypothesis course
so I guess probably if you have been to
cs20 now you know we have talked about
you know if you you can over 30 if you
have too complex or function class but
you don't have enough data and this is
in some sense a mathematical
characterization of that right so if
your function class is too complex
so that the log log of H
is too too big and and you don't have
enough data
um compared to log of H then you may
have a word spot
um and on the other hand suppose your
logophage is small and your n is bigger
than log of H then you have a better
bound which could be meaningful
okay any questions so far
we are doing yes you oh no this is the
the differentiability of the loss
function
um so the loss function is a function of
um
so the loss function is a function of
you know it depending on how you think
about it but by the differentiability I
really mean this function that takes in
y height and Y and output the scalar
so taking a prediction and the real
label and the optical scalar so whether
this function is differentiable with
respects to uh Y and Y hat
so we didn't assume that this function
is differentiable here but implicitly
you are assuming that this loss function
is differentiable with respect to Y and
Y height in the previous estimated
analysis because there actually we
assume the whole loss function if you
compose it with the model has to be
differentiable
foreign
my number
so I didn't hear very well practical
implementation of 24 numbers can you use
like the same
for practical implementations where you
have floating
points
so so I guess my interpretation of the
question maybe let me rephrase the
question a little bit also for the zoom
people on the zoom meeting so I think
the proposal is that uh for example if
you really have a practical model and
you have like a p parameters and uh
um they are you know when you really
implement this in computer it's not
continuous right so you can
think of like each parameter is
described by you know maybe 32 bits and
then you can count how many total
possible number of different models they
are and apply this block right so yes
and that's a good idea and uh and that
will give you what that will give you
that suppose you have P parameters
let's say you have 32 bits
so one bit is so then what does it mean
that means that the total size of H
would be that for every P parameter you
have 2 to the 32 choices
and you multiply that to p
right so you you take the raised power
to p and so that means the log of H
is equals to
something like 32 like all of P right
it's a constant time speed
so basically you don't get the bond that
depends on number of parameters
um and uh and this is uh uh this is
reasonable in some in some cases this is
you know not very reasonable in some
other cases but definitely it's a pretty
it's a it's a bond that makes sense
right so in some of the later parts of
the lecture we are going to see how to
get a bond that doesn't depend on
parameter but if you um if you are fine
with getting a bond that depends the
number of parameters then this is indeed
a good thought
um
and
um and this is actually an actual
question that leads me to the second
part of the lecture today's lecture
um so so this is a proposal where you
the proposal to do this
has a small cons or small kind of
problem which is you basically have to
say that I have to resort to
practical implementation in practice I
cannot really Implement real numbers
right uh all the real numbers I have to
discretize in some way right so that's
and sometimes you put a additional
restriction on yourself saying that you
know if I can only use like uh
like a lack of floating points then what
bound I can have right so what I'm going
to discuss now right next is that you
don't even need this you can even say
that even for all the possible
continuous models with you know
um it's supposed to have P parameters
and each parameter is really a real
number like you can for example suppose
you have for Almighty computer which can
have like
infinite Precision still your bound
would still look like something like
this you still have an old feedback like
uh so so so then you don't have to like
suppose we have that infinite
like called hypothesis class proof then
you don't need this practical
um kind of like a kind of like a like
this this way of proving it right you
can have a more genuine stronger way to
prove it and that's what we're
production
Okay cool so
um
okay so maybe let's let's start to do
that so let's talk about infinite
hypothesis class
and as I suggested you know a little bit
before so we are gonna have a bond that
looks like P Over N square root p over n
and p is number of parameters so this is
something we're going to have
Okay cool so and
um so so today we're gonna do this
so-called like a Brute Force
this conversation
this is a technique of at least this is
how I name this technique I guess
because this technique is too too Brute
Force I guess there's no really real
name for it
um
um and what you can do is the following
so
um
maybe maybe yeah let me say the theorem
we're going to prove first and then I
can tell you um what's the intuition and
how to prove it so so this is a serum so
suppose H is
okay I guess I'm still setting up
suppose H is parameterized by
Theta
in P dimension
so H is you know mathematical you write
H is a family of H substeta each H
subtitle is a parametricized model
where a Theta is in some
set of theta which is a subset of RP so
Capital Theta is the set of parameters
you are going to choose from
and in some sense this is for
um convenience so but I guess you
probably wouldn't see why this is only
for convenience you know but doesn't
really matter so suppose you only select
models from this set
where you
uh where your Norm of the model is
bounded by B
um our dependency on B will be very will
be the only logarithmic so in some sense
this is not really a real restriction
but you can choose B to be pretty big
just because your dependency on B is
very very uh relaxed whereas the
logarithmic in b
so so this is our setup
and
Also let's recall that we sometimes
gonna use this notation
this is really you know we you use all
of these rotations it enter
exchangeably so
either this is really just a loss of
theta the model Theta on the data point
X and Y so it's really just you compare
each state of X and Y and you get a lot
right these two are just the same thing
like we are abusing notation a little
bit and also recall that we have L Theta
L High Theta this is all as we defined
before
and so here's the theorem
so we still have to assume that the loss
is between 0 and 1.
foreign
always assumed in most of this lecture
in most of this course
for every x y and Theta
and suppose
um this is additional assumption
where you assume that
this loss function is calypses
in Theta
so
um
so for every
X and Y so what does this really mean
this really means that
you're assuming L of X Y
Theta minus L of X Y
and Theta Prime if you change your model
to Theta Prime
then your loss wouldn't be differed by
a constant times say the mark centers
minus Theta Prime in two naught
so this may be out let's try to this is
Kappa
so okay so again this
um
the our dependency on Kappa will also be
logarithmic so in some sense this is
also not assuming much like because if
you're if your uh loss is kind of
somewhat continuous then you
um
then you can have a uh it's gonna be
ellipses you know to some extent right
it's probably the Ellipsis constantly
it's not very good but the lips constant
would be something reasonable and if you
take a logarithmic of it it's not very
sensitive to the leftist constants
and then
with this then you got
with probability
at least
one minus
um I guess of e to the minus P so
actually you have even higher
um even lower failure probability the
failure probability is e to the minus p
um so with so small figure probability
you get that for every Theta you have
the uniform convergence
is less than some Big O of square root p
over n
times Max
1
and long
Kappa B and N
so
So eventually
um
the dependency on carbon BR logarithmic
that's what I promised and the main
thing is really P Over N so you get the
uh the parameter dependency and get the
dependency on it
and you still have the square root here
so this is still worse than uh there is
a synthetic Bond if you compare with the
leading term of the asymptotic box but
as we said you know you don't have the
second another term in the asymptotic
Box
okay so how do we how do we
um how to prove this so actually the
proof is very similar to what the what
was suggested in a question so you are
doing a discretization and then you deal
with the the discretization error
separately
so so what you do is the the following
so
um let me start with a kind of a sketch
in some sense so the the the the kind of
the alternate sketch is the following so
you define e Theta
um with the event
that you have this failure event right I
always say that minus L Theta
is larger than episode and Epson is
going to be something TBD but Epson
would be very similar to
this thing right because you care about
whether these two are different right
how like a this much different but
anyway so absolutely some number that is
kind of like a placeholder so you care
about this kind of events and we know
that this will be a small probability
but as we have shown for the final case
right so this e Theta is a small
probability right
and before we call that what we did is
that which we say that the union of this
e Theta is less than the sum of the E
Theta the probability of e Theta
but now because you have infinite number
of theta this is infinite because
um each one has some you know small
probability event right so to fail and
you take the sum over all possible
events then you get infin number at
least
um like like each of these will be some
Epsilon you take the sum of infinite
number of things you get infinite
so that's why it doesn't work right you
cannot use the exactly the same thing as
before
so
um but but the reason why this is uh uh
this can be fixed is because this unit
bond is very pessimistic
so so if you think about Union bank
right so unibong is really just saying
that okay I guess I'm not sure
depending on how you're learning balance
you know
um in quick structures like what I
learned about unibody is this following
for example you have a this is the full
probability space and each
even take some part of space Maybe This
is e Theta 1 this is E1
and this is maybe E2 and the optimal the
when the unibond would be tied it's it's
when all those all of this event
I call it they call them failure device
all of them are destroyed right so right
suppose this is the case then the unit
of these events will be the sum of the
probability of each of the events
but
here it's not clear whether this event
are destroyed and actually it may have a
lot of overlap right so you have one
Theta
and if you change yourself to your
nearby Theta you probably have something
like this which is easy to Prime and
they have all of this overlap and then
your unit Bond starts to be very loose
um so so so so that's also kind of
motivates our way to fix it or the way
that we fix it is the following
so uh we
fix it by
by first picking not up we don't take
unibond over all possible events we
select a subset of events and we take
unibond overdone and then we say the
other events will be close to some of
this this subset of prototypical events
so so basically the idea is that you um
the rough idea is that you selected some
it's like prototypical events
prototypical sorry like just maybe I
should just say typical events or you
just take some example events I don't
know how to I forgot how to spell that
some example events and this is
sometimes of events you um is a smaller
set of events than what you finally care
about and then you use unibond on the
subset
and then you say that other events
are similar to the subset
to the examples
so so then you cover all the events so
that's the the rough idea
so um let's see how we exactly do this
so to exactly do this uh we need to
introduce something called
any questions so far
okay so to exactly do this we need to
introduce something called this created
uh or Epson cover this is actually also
a useful tool
um for other cases as well
so uh let me let me first Define this
Epson cover and then
say Y is
it's kind of like it's a note it's a
it's a language to describe what what
are called prototypical events or
prototypical kind of like
parameters or models so so apps on that
sometimes it's also called epsilonite
sometimes it's called Epson cover
offers that
s and here ice corresponds to the the
family of all models you care about and
you care about the subset of models and
if you this and with respect to
like when you really Define it you have
to specify metric row
row is a set
C which is also a subside of s
but I think technically we don't have to
require C to be a subset device but I
think in almost all cases it's a subset
of s
such that
for every X in s
right so there exists a
kind of a neighbor in C
which is close to X
so
if you if you draw this it's kind of
like
you're saying that you have a set
of models or parameters this is called
as
and the Epson cover is a subset of s
right so as you select some points and
let's call these points
these are all in C
and then you say that this set of C
needs to satisfy the following to be
your Epsilon cover so what it has to
satisfy it has specified that for every
point you pick in x in x where you pick
this on X in US there exists a neighbor
somewhat kind of a neighbor
um in C right let's call this x Prime
I guess I
cross and X seems to be the same I'm not
sure whether maybe I should anyway you
see what I mean like the the purple
cross is just the indicating a point but
okay so you have a point x here and and
you you can always find some other point
in C such that X Prime is kind of close
relax
so so so that's basically is saying that
all of these points in C are
prototypical point of points because
every point in us can find a neighbor in
C
um
that makes sense
and equivalently you can also write this
in the following way so equivalently
this is in sometimes more
explaining why it is called Epsilon
cover so equivalently you can write this
as the s is
covered by the union of the ball
around all the acts
let me write it down and explain what
this is so first of all this is the so
this thing is the ball
centered
right X
with
radius
Epsilon
and and distance metric or Magic
row
so
um so basically this is saying the
following so this is the equivalent
definition of Epsilon cover so you are
saying that if you look at all the the
balls
around all of these purple points
right so this is the the radius is
absolute so in some sense you can say
that this ball so this point covers the
entire ball because for every
point in this ball you can find you can
use the this point the center as the
neighbor
right so so basically every Point covers
some part of the space and so the
requirement is that
if you look at all the points that can
if you look like if you look at the all
the balls around all the centers
then this route cover the entire uh s
right that means that every point in us
can be covered by some ball and that
means every point in us has a neighbor
in C
any questions okay
see
see may not be we will in in some sense
we will insist that see like we need to
find a very small currency which is
finite and also hopefully we want the
size of C to be small but by the
definition there is nothing about
whether it's finite or not but we will
construct Epsilon cover that is finance
right so this is for so far this is only
definition
um saying that c is absolute cover of s
yeah but we will make try to make C to
be small
and this is actually exactly a
so so this is exactly what we're going
to do next right so how do we construct
a set C that is finite and also cover
the entire set right so what is X right
so for us
as is this set of all parameters right
it's the side of parameter Theta with
this L2 Norm less than b
right you're going to construct a subset
of parameters that can cover all the
parameters
right so here is a Lemma that says that
you can do this
and you can have fun and c and also
actually you can have a reasonable Bond
on how many seats how many points in CDR
so uh
so let's let's define this to be I guess
for this Lemma I I call this Theta so so
so Theta is defined as above so for
every Epsilon in 0 and B
um
for every radius there exists an Epsilon
cover
of the stats Theta the L2 Norm with
radius B
such that with
at most
3B over Epsilon to the power P elements
so this is a cover and the the size of
this cover is bounded by 3B over
absolute to the power p
Okay so
so I think this is actually
um we're gonna prove a weaker version
the full
um so we're going to have a homework
question which kind of guide you to
prove the this exactly this version so
for now in the lecture we're going to
prove a weaker version
which is a
um somewhat easier
so this recover version and also
actually suffices for our purpose right
so like you don't really necessarily
need a stronger version to prove the
final theorem just because this like the
weaker version is only weaker by a
little bit so
um
um I guess the homework will guide you
towards the stronger version which also
introduce some techniques which is
useful
um so so here is the a weaker version
the weaker version is pretty much like
you discretize your computer right you
just do a tribute Equalization uh using
some grade
so what you do is you just take C
B uh
a trivia grade in some sense
so what does that mean it really means
that you have this ball
let me sweater
I guess if you have this ball
and you just say that you take that some
arbitrary kind of like a coordinate
system you just take the natural
coordinate system
and you discretize your space like this
and then you take all the the this kind
of points as you'll see
and that's it
so um and then the question is just a
matter of counting on the whole fine
fine grains your grade needs to be
so formally so C is taken to be all the
points X
in RP such that
x i the coordinate
uh is a multi multiple I guess this is K
K times
Epsilon over Square P so Epsilon over
Square p is my grade size
and K is the the integer multiplied with
it
for some integer
foreign
p over Epsilon why I have this
constitution on K because at some point
you don't need more points because you
already
you don't have to do anything beyond
this part right it's because you know if
your case too big you are the outside as
there is no point
so and if you do the calculation this is
the right thing
um and
right so now we have to do two things
one thing is we have to see how large C
is and second thing is we have to prove
that this is the Epson cover
so let's do the first thing so why this
is Epsilon cover
this is because if you look at any point
x in s
you just round it to the nearest uh
nearest Port right so so when you run
that you want it to um to do some
rounding
uh
let's see I guess we run it you're going
to
um
let's call it X Prime right let me not
write exactly what the wrong wrong
number just means you take the any any
vertex
uh in this grid and and along the
nearest any nearly reasonable nearest
like that's what I mean like you just to
do um
the the tribute on it let's say you want
to a smaller number it doesn't really
matter that much so so if you run it so
what you got is that X
I minus x i Prime is less than
Epsilon over Square p
because for every Dimension when wrong
you increase you create Epsilon over
Square P error right F2 over Square p is
your grade size
and that means that the distance between
x and x Prime
in the L2 sense right uh like this is I
guess
sorry I think this is I should mention
that the row
L2 Norm the real
this yeah I should have mentioned this
so the the magic we are using is we
always L2 Norm
right so so then if you look at io2 Norm
of these two uh two things right so
this is the sum of x i minus x i Prime
squared I from 1 to p
and then you Bond each coordinate you
get P times Epsilon Square over p
square root which is absolute that's
actually why I chose the grid size to be
Epsilon over Square p just because I
want to to make it absolute like that
so this proves that is the Epsom Carver
right so and also we can count how large
C is
so C is what C is something to the power
P because for every coordinate you have
a batch of choices for K and how many
choices of okay there are
basically this was in here is like pay
the absolute value of K is less than b
squared p over F sub y so basically
you've got B squared p over Epsilon and
because it can be positive and active
that's why you must buy two and you can
also be zero so you add one so that's
that's the total number of choices
uh in C
right so and
one comment is that I eventually Only
log C markers as you see so log c will
be P log 2B Square p over Epsilon plus
one
and that's why this weaker version is
not super different from the stronger
version because the difference right so
the stronger version was
the stronger version was 3B over Epsilon
to the power p
and the log
becomes P log 3B over Epsilon and if you
compare the stronger version with the
weaker version the only thing is
different is the square p in the log so
that's why eventually it doesn't change
the bonds too much
um
Okay cool so this is our
um proof for the the weaker version of
dilemma
um and now let's uh uh let's use this
Lemma and the Epson cover to prove the
the final bound right so as we kind of
like a plant what we do is that we first
apply
um
apply fun in the hypothesis case
uh
the the final hypothesis you know
analysis
to C
and then you say that uh
uh you then use somewhat so this may be
let's say this is number one and then
you say that
um
extent
one to the whole set as
okay so now the the first step should be
trivial because we already prove it
right so so if you want to do I then
basically you got that
um if you
the first thing is that you do it for
every
fix the Theta uh in C
then you have probability of this
Epsilon if you use whole thing in
quality you get this is I guess let's
call it Epson tilde because this Epson
field will be tuned to be decided later
on to make the the bonds fit so you got
this is two times exponential minus two
and Epsilon Square
this is by halfting
exactly the same thing as we have done
before
and then you take a unit Bond
is you got that probability that for
every Theta I guess
to existed
Theta in C
such that this is not right
is small
and how small it is you multiply C with
this
exponential minus 2 and absence Theta
squared
okay so these two steps are exactly as
we did and
if you flip this you get uh
uh you get one minus so probability of
a good event happens with high
probability
I'm just flipping
okay so now we have to do the Second
Step how do we extend this to for
everything in US
and
um
so second and we are basically using
ellipsislessness
and you can see that this is you know
not really anything super clever it's
kind of like a Samsung Brute Force right
so so
um
okay so just for some quick preparation
so because l x Theta
is
Kappa ellipses this is Kappa
lips it's
in Theta this implies that
hello Theta and L has data
are both copper lipses
why this is just because you know if
your average two function to look copper
loopsis function there are still couple
notches right so
f is copper ellipsis
G is copper lipsense
f plus G over 2 is also copper lips
and you can prove this by a simple
triangle inequality
um and you can do this for multiple
functions not only just two functions
you can do it for n functions
okay so suppose we have this then
uh
now so we we also know that for so
suppose we know for every so
we already know that for every data
right so IO High Theta minus so suppose
we condition on this event
right so so with some chance you know
with a very high probability this
happens and suppose this happens let's
condition on this event we want to prove
that the same thing happens when you
replace C by Theta by S right so this
means that if you have for every Theta
in
I guess I call it capital city but not s
right Capital say that the ball
you can find
consider zero in C
such that Theta minus the zero
L2 is less than absolute this is by the
definition of absent cover where C is
absolute cover of capital Theta that's
why you have this
and then this implies that
zero
is less than copper times Epsilon this
is voluptuousness
right so
and so in some sense you just use
cellular zero as a reference point right
so what you finally care about is L
height Theta minus l
sorry I guess you also know this you
don't only know this you also know
High Theta minus L Theta High Square
zero
is less than Kappa times F so this is
also by ellipsis
foreign
Ty and IO Theta
right so and we have seen this kind of
triangle in the quality you know this
kind of like a manipulation already
right because you know eventually you
get you care about the difference
between L hat and L but the user said
that zero some reference points to kind
of bridge them so you you do this
decomposition you say that this is L hat
Theta minus L height Theta zero
plus IO High to the zero
minus l0
plus IO zero minus L Theta
and now these two things are about
differences between Theta and zero zero
so
this quantity is less than copper times
Epsilon
and this quantity is also less than
copper times Epsilon and this quantity
is less than
Epsilon
this is because Theta 0 is in C
right so we have already proved that for
everything in C you know L higher Theta
is equals to is close to L Theta so
um so that's why we got this three
inequality right so so in total if you
look at the absolute value
then you can do the Triangular quality
to get the absolute value of the sum of
the sum of the absolute value of each of
them you get two Kappa times Epsilon
Plus
uh
oh absolutely so sorry this is absolute
because so recall that I use a different
app zone for the for the concentration
just so that I can tune this Epson tilde
uh eventually
okay so and if I now if it's the time to
start
uh episode to be absolute tilde over two
Kappa or maybe you you can do it another
way around like Epson 20 to be absent
times to cover
then you get
you buy it so so that you balance these
two hour terms you get this is less than
uh
two apps on children
okay
so
okay
um
all right so now let's look at the uh
um what's the
let's go back to here
right because here there is something
about the cover size we have a deal with
right we have to plug in the right
covers Us
so and what is the cover size so the
cover size was
so lock cover size
uh log C
is equals to log
3B over Epsilon to the power p and I
have already set Epsilon to be absolute
over 2 Kappa so I need to plug in that
so I got
p and let's first look at this and then
let's plug in the choice of epson tilde
okay P log
three
B copper absolute
and you can see that copper is inside
the log so so that's why it's somewhat
not instant not sensitive the choice of
copper and also absolute children is
also in the log
so which is also nice
um
and and now we have to care about this
failure probability right so we
basically want to say that this is
equals to something like the or
something like uh Delta right so we want
uh to bounce
the failure probability to see
exponential
minus 2 and Epsilon 2 the square right
so this is something about I want to
show that this is small actually in this
case
I'm hoping to show that this exponential
minus p
okay so
um
okay so so how do we show this and of
course it depends on what Epsilon tilde
is right so you need to choose the right
absolute Fields such as this is true and
then that's your final basically your
final box
um and just to get something cute so
you're gonna see that this you know the
exact calculation of this is gonna be a
little bit complicated
um but just to get some intuition here
right so suppose
um
suppose so this is a heuristic which is
not not even technically correct but
it's it's approximately correct
so suppose
like a optimistically the log C is
equals to P instead of P times instead
of
P Times log 3 B over Epsilon
3 because of our Epsilon tilde
so suppose you just have P you don't
have the log chart actually this becomes
a very simple calculation
so
um so what you got is that
you got
um
so basically if you take the log of this
desired inequality
you want that
um
let me see
if you take the log you get log 2 which
is not super important you get a log 2
times log C
minus 2 and epsometer square and suppose
log C is equal to P then you get P minus
2 and Epsilon Square
and if you take Epsilon
tilt that to be squared p over n
then you get this is equals to
uh
P minus 2p
right is equal to minus p
right so so which means that 2C
exponential minus two and Epsilon square
if you take the exponential back you get
this is less than exponential minus p
so so this is a
this is fundamentally how it works
okay but we did make this uh incorrect
assumption that log C is equal to P but
this assumption is not very far right so
it's only off by a log Factor so if you
want to fix this you know technically
you need to deal with the log Factor it
wouldn't change much but it would
introduce a little bit kind of like
complication
so I did have the the calculation here
I'm just going to basically write it um
write it down but I don't actually
expect that you follow all of this it
took me like one hour to even figure out
all the constants so and so forth It's
not super important I think the
intuition is already there
um so but let me just quickly write this
just to say what you do formally
so if you suppose log C is equal you
only have this Bond right so this is
what we only have
this is 6p
Kappa over Epsilon tilde
and then let's take
I have some Tudor to be
square root some constant times P Over N
times Max this is actually this absolute
is actually the absolute is the bound is
the final Bond right so that's why
you're gonna see
kind of the same thing
and then final box and c0 is a
sufficient large constant
c0 is a sufficient large constant which
will choose a little bit later
so and and you're plugging all of this
and you just uh again you take the you
look at the log of the inequalities we
care about the log of it is this
and you plug in uh this choice of C you
get P log Six B
copper over absolute
minus 2 and epsilometer square and you
somehow know that if you don't ignore
this log it's already work it's just you
if you have the log you still have to
deal with it
so you get uh
something like P log I'm not even sure
whether I really have to
write down all of this but just in case
some of you want to
have this hardcore calculation
right so you got this and then
you
somehow I guess this the first term
becomes log six
the couple you explain the first term
square root c0pu
I guess I decompose this into
okay guys I'm decomposing the first term
6 over c0p minus C 0 p
log Kappa b n
I guess you know the the way that I
always kind of think about this is that
you know when you do the calculation you
always check with what happens if you
don't have the log right so what if you
don't have to lock then this term is a
large constant times p on this term is p
so that's that's why it's nice
So eventually you can if it takes c0 to
be something like 32 36 I think you can
show that this is bigger than this one
and this one I think I guess I
and this one is inactive when p is large
and then you got this is less than minus
P I guess the exact calculation there is
some more detailed calculation in the
notes but it doesn't matter that much
right so
um so that's that's what we do so then
basically this is saying that if you
take an exponential so you guys of this
inequality you guys 2C
exponential minus two and Epsilon 0
square is less than two times
exponential minus P so this is our
failure probability
um so basically with this probability so
with probability larger than one minus
of e to the minus p
will have our historical minus L Theta
is less than 2 Epsilon tilde
which is this uh thing that we did we
um we want it I mean not just not copy
it again so
Okay cool so so that's the proof and
this proof is a little messy and this is
probably one of the reasons why if you
open up a classical machine book they
would they typically don't show you this
groove uh so it's just because it's a
little messy but but actually it's um
the reason why I always try to show this
proof is that I feel like it's very
intuitive
um uh and it demonstrates what's really
is going on and that's also this kind of
things it's actually useful for many
uh for money reasoning works if you're
looking if you look at a technical
low-level details so so the fancy is
rather more complexity thing that we are
going to talk about next you know they
are very nice but sometimes they don't
apply and you have to really use this
you go back to the most Brute Force way
to think about it
um
right okay so maybe just a
a few quick comments
about this proof
I guess if you really uh think about
this this is really saying that you have
a generalization error
right so it is less than
the log of this excess risk right
up to constant factor of course plus
Epsilon to the k
so so this part is from the finance uh
hypothesis case and this one comes from
the so this is not okay this is Kappa
so this is the discretization error
and this is the finite
hypothesis case
and in some sense you're just trading
all of these two
and and what what does it mean by
chilling off this too it really means
that
um what apps on you choose right so this
one depends on episode
so so this one depends on episode but it
depends on apps on your very weak way
because it depends on Epson in the
logarithm logarithmic so that that make
it you know very easy to trade off this
because you can pick up some to be quite
small so that this term becomes small
and this term
this depends on sorry I think
technically this should depend on log 1
over Epsilon so
all right so the app the smaller the app
zone is the better the second term but
the worst the first term but the first
term increase as Epsilon goes to zero
very slowly
so that's why you pretty much can ignore
the second term in some sense just
because you take absolutely very small
so that the second term becomes
negligible and even when those for those
small apps on the first term it's still
reasonably bonded and that's that's why
you can make this trade off really nice
um but in some other cases you know as
you will see in the later phase right
we'll do the discrete decision the first
term wouldn't be as nice as this it
wouldn't be locked while reps it would
be something that goes to Infinity as
absolute zero in a faster rate right so
we're probably you know in the later
case
later sometimes this this first term
will be y over Epsilon Square then the
the tradeoff will becomes a little bit
more tricky and you have to be more
um more careful about the trade-off
um and finally
um just uh for kind of like this is a
kind of probably all overview for
um
just like a kind of like a from some of
the birds as view right so log h
or p in this case right so
or the the P you can think of this as
complex measures I guess I've mentioned
this
uh as well right so these are complex
measures of the hypothesis class
so um and and the general like a
phenomenon is always like you have a
bigger age
it means that you need more samples
this is always like you have worse Bond
so which means you need more samples to
learn
um and and in some sense the next uh
well two weeks we are talking about
um
a more
accurate
I guess accurate may not be the right
word like a more
um fingering hypothesis more fragrant
complex measure so so what are you is
the right complex measure there is no
really
um a super decisive answer what's the
right complex measure in some sense it's
up to uh up to the theorem approval in
some sense so
um but we're gonna have a more
fine-grain and more in sometimes
fundamental complex measure in the in
the next two lectures which is called
random marker complexity and
and you can use that to derive many of
these Bonds in your more principal way
so and in general I think uh one of the
important questions for you know
especially in the Summer's classical
statistical machine learning is to find
out what's the right complex measure for
your hypothesis class
right so we're going to discuss you know
what does it really mean by right and
wrong like there's no unique answer
right so
um
um but but there are some kind of like
but this is kind of the essential
question right so you need a complex
measure that really captures the
the fundamental complexity of this of
this class for example if you have an
infinite carbon's class right so you
shouldn't use log H log H is not really
the fundamental complex measure for
infinite hypothesis you probably should
use dimensionality probably in the later
of the course we are going to see if you
can use the norm of your parameters as
the as the complex measure so and and it
does depend on the the specific cases
and also sometimes depends on data so
this will be what we discussed uh in the
in the next few weeks
um I think this is a natural place to
stop
um yeah okay I think that's all for
today